as workplaces swelter
key areas of the economy are at breaking
point with huge swathes of the
population
being forced into isolation by the nhs
kovid app
creative nature sells super food snacks
to a global market
and they're worried about the next few
weeks i do feel this is quite
hard on businesses in general because
how
how are they going to control it how are
we going to move forward with it
is it just going to be constant is going
to be a ping and then a week later
another ping
the pandemic as it's been called is a
double whammy for many sectors of the
economy
ports are now experiencing significant
levels of staff
absence as high as 10 percent in some
places
the knock-on for supply chains is
enormous
and high street giants are also
suffering with some warning
stores may have to close early
it could turn into a long hot febrile
summer
frontline health workers will be exempt
from self-isolation
in exceptional circumstances but many
nurses are furious
at the government's handling of this
crisis
why are we not being protected as a
workforce why are we not being protected
to ensure patient safety why do we have
to go to work and put others at risk
willingly
because our government is telling us to
do it i think it's absolutely abhorrent
there is significant frustration amongst
many businesses
struggling anyway to make ends meet the
calls to make the app less sensitive
have been dismissed by the authorities
the problem
the government has is balancing the
opening of the economy freedom day
with a pandemic that is still raging
it's why boris johnson
says that test race and isolate is still
an essential part of the country's
response
in fact because of the political choices
that have been made
it's one of the few levers left to pull
in the face
of a rapidly rising infection rate
the government has ruled out a critical
jobs list
instead employers will have to apply for
an exemption from isolation
but only for workers who've been fully
vaccinated
at this food packaging plant where
they're struggling to recruit enough
staff
the dreaded ping and its bureaucracy is
another thing
to contend with it sounds like this
could be a real admin burden for us to
try and figure out
who's being vaccinated who's allowed
back who's not and then to apply on a
case-by-case basis
britain is now not only dealing with the
pandemic
it's also in the grip of a pindemic this
week was supposed to be about getting
things back to normal
but despite what the government says the
road to freedom
looks far from clear alex rossi
sky news surrey